في امريكا حيث اقوى اقتصادات العالم
تتعاظم المخاوف من العجز عن سداد الديون
المستحقه في الخامس من يونيو المقبل وسط
ازمه رفع سقف الدين المشتعله بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
انظار العالم في هذا التوقيت تتجه نحو
الدولار
والتساؤلات حول امكانيه التاثر واحده من
اقوى العملات حول العالم
وكانت التصنيف الائتماني العالمي موديز بث
التطمينات بان العمله الامريكيه ستحتفظ
بموقعها على راس العملات على الرغم من كل
التحديات لكن ما هي الدول التي تستدين
منها امريكا
تحتفظ خمس دول بالقدر الاكبر من الديون
اعتبارا من يناير 2023
تتقدمها الصين واليابان
فاليابان بتريليون ومئه مليار دولار تليها
الصين ب 859 مليار دولار اما المملكه
المتحده فتملك
668 مليار دولار
الرابعه بلجيكا بثلاثمائه واحد وثلاثين
مليار دولار
والخامسه لوكسمبورغ بثلاثمائه وثمانيه عشر
ابرز الاسباب التي تدفع تلك الدول
الاجنبيه لشراء الديون الامريكيه هو ان
سندات الخزانه الامريكيه تعتبر واحده من
اكثر الاصول امانا في العالم
اذ تلتزم الحكومه الامريكيه سواء كانت
ديمقراطيه ام جمهوريه بسداد الديون في
الوقت المناسب كما يمكن ايضا ان يوفر
امتلاك سندات الخزانه الامريكيه مزايا
اضافيه مثل تنويع المحفظه بالاضافه الى
معدل عائد اعلى مقارنه بالسندات الحكوميه
الاخرى المتاحه في جميع انحاء العالم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات